and i saw
khabib fight his last fight right
and something really caught my attention
like he's a main character
and he plays a big role in in the film
in the sinaloa cartel
they do a lot of witchcraft craft with
new mexico they deal with a lot of gin
over there
in in mexico and for me that was like
just like go like
like stories to scare kids right
i felt this gin grab my ham brother
like he grabbed he his his fingers were
so long
that he went like
masha'allah allah
[Applause]
now our next guest was living in a very
dark world
in a very dark place in life the only
thing he believed in was death
as he had encountered so much of it he
was a high-ranking
member of one of the main carnatell
organizations in mexico
gunfights with government agents and
other cartels
until he thought of actually killing
himself because
he had touched the rock bottom in life
so we want to find out with our next
guest
how islam and the quran impacted his
life
so much so that he's actually on the
dean's show with my next guest
go ahead and subscribe right now hit
that notification bell help us get our
numbers back up did you know that
many years ago the dean show when we
started 2006 we used to broadcast for
many years on the khalifa clothing
channel
currently known as digital minbot so
we're trying to get our numbers back up
because the channel
at that time got closed then we started
the official d show channel we're trying
to get our numbers back
up to where they should be and that's
this number here 855 combined what we
currently have 442
we should be over a million 200
000 subscribers help us to get our
numbers
back to where they should be with that
small setback that we had many years ago
you guys can help us by subscribing
right now and hitting that notification
bell
thank you very much enjoy the rest of
this show salaam and don't forget to
support us on our patreon page hello
american brother
how are you doing my brother i'm doing
pretty good
how are you i'm good hamdulillah so
so you were you're you were actually a
high-ranking member
in the cartel yeah
um i i i belonged to several cartels
um before i went to jail
i worked for a first for a small cartel
um down in mexico city i ended up going
to jail and then i
i ended up going back to the cartels
working for a bigger organization
because of um
what i did inside of jail you know what
i had uh the reputation i had
earned inside of uh prison but it's it
was really difficult you know
it's been um it's been a really long
journey
so for people that don't know what the
cartel is
we're going to go ahead and share
with them a short little video here
so they can kind of get an idea the kind
of lifestyle you were
this year on record despite hopes that
the covet 19 crisis would slow down
violent crime
it's had the opposite effect more than
17 000 people were murdered in the first
half of this year alone
in kuliakan a city of about 800 000 in
the headquarters of the notorious and
lower cartel
no one is off limits for ernesto
martinez
it's the brutality of the killings that
stand out
[Music]
jesus manuel was a 42 year old local
police officer
a few days before he turned up dead he'd
been kidnapped by cartel members
[Music]
that's his brain hey oh
man really why would they have done this
like what what
was he involved with them in some way
[Music]
an element
so i'm sure people get the point now you
know so
how do you go from you're born in mexico
raised came at an early age to
california
and now how do you end up in such a
organization
um you know they i was i was taken to
uh to california when i was like a year
i don't have
i don't have memories of mexico i grew
up in california i went to school in
california
you know the the type of lifestyle
that's here in california knows a lot of
gangs
you grew up with a lot of racism um
and it was like my my family my family
actually was my family's christian right
um i grew up in in the christian church
going to a baptist church
but something happened when i was really
young um
my family got torn apart my father ended
up uh
in in state prison and it was
it's actually something really really uh
really personal
in my in in our life what what he did to
our
our family he broke our family apart
right
and it was like i would i would uh
i was really young when that happened uh
the last time i saw him i think i was
10. um and i haven't seen him since you
know but
i was really mad at the time because
like i would say to myself like
out i would see my mom that my mom was
going to church
and she would always take us to church
and and i and i would say like
why did why did this happen to us if if
my mom was looking for
for god you know um i was too young to
to actually like really believe in god
but i i would never like
i would never see that like i would see
christianity sometimes you know like
[Music]
wondering like why why would you guys
worship a human being
what was so special of him to be
crucified to be killed
i when i was younger when i when i was
younger i was really
like i was i was um grown to be like
i i grew up being proud of who i was
being proud of i was met because i was
mexican you know
that it was it was all about that that
brown and proud of that mexican pride
that like always came up like like
that's the type of person i i was
um when when my family was broken apart
like i started
doing things i shouldn't do you know
hanging around with the wrong people i
i ended up um you know like like any
normal kid you know stealing
just like i would sometimes like try to
like
do do stuff just like try to help my mom
because i would i would i would see my
mom
at like at 9 10
12 at night crying you know because she
had uh she was left alone with four kids
i was the oldest one
and she had never worked in the us
she didn't speak english she spoke only
spanish
and i really like i was i was too young
no to to see what had happened
what my father had done in my family uh
the way that he had destroyed my family
you know
um i started just like looking for an
excuse
to to to belong to to gangs you know to
to start doing
criminal criminal activity basically my
mom told me like hey um
if you're gonna follow that life like
stay away from your brothers because
you're going to give them a bad example
right
and i was like i would always try to
like blame that
what had happened with my father um
in in our family and like i would always
try to blame that like oh i'm i'm gonna
i'm i'm
i'm following the way i'm i'm going
because uh because of what he did to our
family
but i was just looking for an excuse
right um
i started getting into trouble and i and
i was like
i had to leave the i had i had to leave
the u.s and i had to
just try to like look for something
different because of the problems that
i was uh i was getting into
but i didn't know that it's it's very
difficult in mexico and it's even
even more crazier i i had no idea to
to what extent i was going to get
involved right you had no no idea what
was waiting for you
exactly like i i thought that that was
bad like that they were
like they were bad like they were they
were real gangsters i had no idea
of what the human being is capable of
doing you know
i came down to mexico um
life is really hard right because it's
like it's it's a third world country
uh this there's not a lot of money
um i went to the south part of mexico
it's a there's a
there's a small state called uh guerrero
um i was there for a couple of months i
didn't like it and i moved to
to a state that's close to mexico city
but
i still felt like i i felt i felt alone
because i didn't i didn't know anybody
right
um i met a person that i consider my
brother because like um
he saw that he saw what i was going
through
it's been a long time you know since
i've seen my mom when i left them
i was really young when i started
walking by myself
when i started trying to like live by
myself so it gets like
it for me like christmas new year were
really bad days like because i would see
like all the families get together right
and and i would remember what happened
to my family how my dad had affected our
family
and a lot of people like they they would
probably want to know
i don't want to share what happened to
my family because i
i don't want to like um it was something
difficult you know i just don't want to
i
i don't want to say it but it was
something that that was really personal
that i think that if if i would have
been like if if
that would have happened if my dad would
have done what he did
when i was a little bit older i would
have probably took in his life you know
at the time i couldn't because i was too
young you know
i was too scared and and and what he
what he had done what he had done
affected us really hard um
so when i came down here i i met this
this person that i really
he really cared for me his name his name
was martin
he had uh we called them his nickname
was ninote you know
he he was from border brothers from uh
from san diego
he was living in the south and and he
when when i met him he's like hey
i'm gonna show you some homie love you
know and uh
he gave me some stuff and he's like
whenever you want to kick it you come
down here
so i started kicking it with him you
know he was so he was a small store for
for uh for for a criminal organizing
organization right
but he started showing me loyalty and he
started showing me that
that i wasn't alone um
i had already done a couple of things
you know i hadn't been that involved
in in in the type of life that that that
requires you to be in the organization
so i like a lot of people ask me like
why did you join like did you join
because of you you needed money you
needed power
i didn't the the government's so corrupt
down here
and like society's so corrupt
like um they killed they killed him in
front of his kids right
they they gunned them down in front of
his kids um this friend of yours
yeah this friend of mine and they
when when that happened you know like i
went to his funeral
and i noticed that you know you don't
have friends like
before he got killed like a lot of a lot
of like almost all like in in that
barrio in that mario
a lot of a lot of the friends he would
have a lot of friends when he was alive
because he
he would sell drugs right he he sold we
like there's because there's different
type of drugs
but um i would see that they were like
everybody was his friend
while he was alive but when he got
killed i consider him a friend because i
was very loyal to him because he showed
me he
he showed me a lot of capitalism you
know a lot of brotherhood
when when he killed when he got killed
um
i was like well i was the only one me
and me and a 13 year old kid
that would that he uh to this day he he
tells me
like you guys were like you're like you
guys were like my big brothers you know
because we would we would like tell them
hey what are you doing like don't hang
around with those people
because they're they're smoking crystal
they're doing cocaine
you know we were always trying to like
keep them away like hey stay in school
you know like uh
try to take care of them because we knew
where we were at and we knew where we
were heading
when this happened like i had a lot of
like i had i had a lot of uh
anger in my heart i i wanted to get
revenge for what happened right
so i got in i got in contact with the
people that he was working for
and and they were like do you have
experience like what have you done and
like i told them well i have experience
i'm not scared
but alright then let's go they took me
they gave me
they gave me equipment they gave me
people and
and i started working you know i started
working but with with that mentality
that i'm gonna get
i'm gonna get those persons i'm gonna
get those people back i'm gonna get
those people back
when when i was i i wasn't able to bury
him because those same people that that
killed him they were trying to they were
looking for me as well
um and it really hurt me you know to see
that that none of the
none of those those those persons that
would say that they were your friends
they don't they're not there when when
you die you know
though those are just fake friends that
that the world gives you
and when i started getting involved in
this you know i started like
growing because i was not afraid you
know i've always been like that type of
i've
always had that type of warrior
mentality i found my damn imma die
fighting you know
and i i did i did start getting those
people that had done that to my brother
but i ended up in a situation where i
got caught up you know
i got caught up with uh with weapons
and with some drugs you know i got
caught up i got i got caught by the uh
by the mexican government so they they
they they catch me and and um they give
they torture me right
they're like hey you're not because i
had already been i had already been uh
once caught because i got caught with
the
with the nine millimeter because we were
going to go do do a
a business but the the government caught
us
but i went to i went into uh to the
holding cells and like
the cartel got me out real quick the
second time they got me
they're like you're not gonna leave them
but i like i know the laws here so i was
like nah like
like i'm just gonna pay the i'm gonna
pay the the fine for the for the
for the weapons i'm gonna sign for the
drug and i'm gone
um i didn't i wasn't expecting that that
that the mexican government was going to
change
change things around and they were going
to put me a murder case you know
because they knew i was working for that
organization they knew
i didn't say anything about the
organization because i know how things
are here you know
when you say something when you rat
someone out you
you get dealt with and sometimes by the
same by the same government the
government like he's they're just
testing you
if you say if you talk about if you talk
about the the mafia or if you talk about
the cartel
they won't report you they that you got
they they you uh they
they have you they'll take you and
they'll they'll give you up
so you got to see a lot of different
scary things how you talk about this
being just a really dark world
i can't imagine when when this happened
like
when they put me when they got when i
was uh
that murder when i got that murder case
um
i went into prison right and i would see
a lot of like
um i wasn't a believer like i i didn't
believe like even if i had i had that
christianity like i had been in
uh as a kid i had been uh
i grew up in christianity i didn't
really believed in it
i i started saying a lot of weird things
you know like down here in mexico
there's no what they believe in a lot of
a lot of people believe in
the holy death right have you heard of
that have you heard of her
yeah let me uh actually i was that's
what i'm going to ask you
there's a couple couple video clips here
i wanted to uh
ask your question on this
are you familiar with this yeah
for the audience tell us and the reason
i played this clip because i i wanted
you you talked about there's a lot of
different weird things and
a lot of different things they worship
but this talisman actually
around his neck uh is that familiar is
this yeah
yeah yeah they're they're amulets you
know you you get them from
from from high from high ranking witches
or or
uh how do you say how do you how do you
call them um
talismans yeah they like they basically
they they
they kill someone and like they'll
they'll offer them to a specific uh
deity or whatever they believe in wow
and and that will protect you
um so give our audience this person now
that
the authorities are catching he kind of
like
hell broke loose man they don't like
the government has let organizations
grow so big
like he's a main character and he plays
a big role in in the film
in the sinaloa cartel when when they
when they caught him
and they caught him by accident like
they weren't trying to get him
like hell broke loose in in in kuliakan
like 100 to 500
trucks came down from the from the
ceiling the from the sinaloa uh
sierra the mountain ranges they came
specifically to to free him or they were
going to start a war
and it got crazy man it got really crazy
but it just
it's just a small demonstration and this
is um this is a main city
of mexico and they had this much impact
now
this is what you see in the city like
where we were at
and and where we had where i have been
like i've seen to
thousands of trucks like up to 10 000
strong cartels like my cartel
is is one of the it's it's a one it's
like um
they have a they they have a pact with
with this cartel right with the sinaloa
cartel
because the cinema cartel works from
from the half of
of mexico from work where sinaloa is
up to north they they control that part
and we're down in the south uh hitting
with the border
so there's a lot of alliances between
cartels right
and and there is a lot of like there's a
lot of wars also
all right so is this what you were
talking about yeah that's what i'm
talking about
so before before i joined the the uh
before i fell into prison like i had
already seen a couple of people with
with the holy death you know
i i've never been like a believer in in
that i was very supe
superstitious of anything that was
paranormal right
or none of those things so so you have
these uh these
superstitions that people believe that's
what we and then you have
so many cases of shirk now you obviously
know as you're
a new muslim but you know what obviously
the difference between uh the pure
monolithism
the tahit versus so you see a ton of
[__]
happening tell us uh we're almost out of
time
what happened now how did islam how did
you in the depths of all this darkness
get exposure you talk about you heard
the quran and it brought you to tears
um basically when i when i left prison i
i left with with a lot of experience
right because i i
we had a couple of situations going
inside and i started believing in the
holy desk because like i would see that
a lot of people that would help me out
were believers in in this in in her
when i came out i joined i i
joined a very a very large organization
and i spent a lot of time um
doing things i wasn't supposed to i
started growing in there
but at the same time i started seeing
that people that
like you're just a pawn in the in a big
in a bigger in a better game
when when you don't when when you're not
when you're long when you're uh no
longer required
you're gonna get cut off by the same
people and maybe
like now maybe uh it's not even like
it's not even from the top
someone else that that that wants what
you have
he's gonna do he's gonna do something to
to take that away
i had it run into a lot of hard
situations where we had encountered
government
and we we we've we had to really fight
our way out
and like my mentality was was in in
in that i knew i was gonna die there i
knew that my life was gonna end
fighting and and and belonging to these
cartels
and that mentality of knowing that i was
gonna die like i wasn't afraid of it you
know i was ready to die
and we had we i have i've been really
close to death a lot a lot of times
but what actually started scaring me was
that i wasn't scared of dying
but what was there to come after death
like i started noticing a lot of things
i um a lot allah sent me a dream before
i left that before i left the
organization and i saw myself getting
killed
by by my own people right by the whole
people that i was working for
i didn't know about god i really didn't
believe in it but i just said like
out of nowhere like i just had to leave
you know i just i
had that necessity in my heart just to
leave like just what are you doing like
you're gonna you're gonna die for
something that has no
has no no value you're gonna die for
people that are that that are not loyal
to you
so i decided to leave like out of
nowhere just
got up left in the morning like when
they woke up they were looking for me
like crazy because i had a lot of people
that were working for me and i had a con
control over some large territory of
that cartel
i just left i ended up in a small city
renting a a a small room
um had nothing just by myself you know
and i really didn't know what was like
the what was the purpose of my life i
didn't know why i was still alive
when i was when i had to be dead right
and i started getting
i started fighting into depression
because of what i had and what i did
to what i was where i was at and i had
that little voice like
you're a coward like you're a coward i
thought you were gonna i thought you
were gonna die for those people
okay i thought you were gonna die in the
fight you know that's that's like
i felt really lost like really really
last man and i started getting scared
because like of
the whispers i would hear like i
couldn't find peace like i
i i couldn't find something you know and
got to the point where
i sat down at my bed and i was thinking
of like
should i kill myself man like like i'm
not i have not done anything
beneficial for no one here in this life
like why you actually got to a point
where you're contemplating suicide huh
yeah at all
definitely brother that it got really
scary and that's that's where the moment
where i ain't even like i just closed my
eyes and i i
i said like i don't know if you really
exist or if you're hearing me this
but like god is merciful brother
and it's hard
because like i don't know how
you know like
i look at my life and and i guess like
god is
most merciful
i just asked him like i didn't even know
how to call on him you know because i
had never looked
towards him
and i knew that i had never i hadn't
done i hadn't been a
i ain't i hadn't been a good person man
and i just asked them like let me know
that you're that you're real let me know
guide me to something that is real
because i i'm gonna lose myself you know
i'm gonna lose myself here
where i am the next day
i'm into boxing right i do muay thai
i'm into sports you know i've always
liked to kept myself really healthy
and and i saw khabib fight his last
fight right
and something really caught my attention
when
when at the end of his fight he would
always give glory to god you know
and i started like looking up because
the only the only thought the only
thing i knew about islam was that
like what what the west showed you what
what they
what they try to show teach you about it
like
that they're a bunch of terrorists
when i started hearing the rest of like
uh recitations of the holy quran
like my heart was looking for something
was looking for something real man when
i heard it
it would break it would break me and
until this day man
like i'm thinking of writing a book of
whatever because it's like my story is
very long
and and that point was the point that it
was like
i had to know more i had to know more
and and it's true
what the quran says only only god guides
who he wills
so you are asking that you are a living
testimony
that if someone is sincere and they can
be in the cartel
they can be in the mafia they could be
in the darkest place
in the darkest room on the darkest night
the darkest hole wherever they are in
life
but if they do what you did sincerely
asking the creator the heavens and the
earth
you didn't know how to call upon him you
just asked for the guidance you said
guide me
exactly got it you didn't you didn't
pray to a saint
you didn't pray to a human being to an
angel to
jesus to anybody but the one who jesus
prayed to
the one who the messengers prayed to the
one who we are called
to pray to the one who created creation
the one and only creator of the heavens
and earth god almighty allah so you
prayed
to the creator directly and alone
and you asked for guidance you didn't
call him at that time you didn't say
allah
no what did you say you were just in
spanish or what was
in english i i i just
closed my eyes because i was i was
getting to the point where i was looking
where to hang myself from right in
prison i learned how a lot of people
a lot of people in prison a lot of some
of my friends they hanged themselves
because they had
so you were looking you were looking
left right where to hang yourself and at
that time you're
now asking this is your last it was just
it was like am i breaking my breaking
point you know
because like i was mad i was mad towards
myself
because i like there was a part of me
that was saying like
you're a coward man like you're ready to
die like why did you leave like why did
you leave everything behind
shaytan is coming now shaitaan is
starting to oh and it got worse man it
got worse like i had never had
experience
with with jin until i actually
came until i actually was striving to to
to follow
uh the teachings of islam and and
instead of getting like instead of being
scared
it even it even um
affirmative like it made stronger my
belief in what i was what i was looking
for you know because
at that point like i
i always take care of myself right i'm
always taking care of myself
legally because i i don't want to get
caught back up
i said i'm not going back to prison and
i'll die i'd rather fight
with government then go back to britain
because of one of
the the experiences that i learned in in
in prison
now that i turn around and i look at my
life and and i see that god has guided
me to a different
to a different place everything falls
and
everything falls in everything falls
into perfect
into a into a perfect plan he is the
most he's the most great
and he had the perfect plan because a
lot of people
like a lot of my friends that i still
talk to they ask me
like they don't they don't believe that
like what are you talking about man
you're you're you're the devil because
what we
what we what we've done is cartel
members
there's no forgiveness you know that i
would i before it before i became
a muslim i would say like i have no
forgiveness what i've done
subhanallah i i have
i knew i was going to die a
the way i was going to die because of
the things that had i have done
you know and when i and when i got when
i was in that point
the breaking point where i was already
looking for like where to hang myself
um and it and it it it was scary man
because like
i didn't find like i couldn't find a
purpose like what made like
you were so scared of dying when you
were ready at that when you had
encountered so many so many problems and
and so many very dangerous uh situations
like
i had bullets flying like i had like the
cars that we were driving like they
would get shot up by the army by
by government and nothing happened to me
and a lot of people were telling me like
because uh because i i like i started
believing in in in
in this in in this saint and i would and
i would carry
i would carry a talisman as well you
know like protection
and one of the friend one of my friends
told me like you know you know that she
only takes care of you for a certain
time
and then and then your time your time's
up you know
and i told them like we're not afraid of
dying bro
like this is what this is who we are
to the extent that the devil shaitan
misleads people
to that to that extent and because i
didn't know any i didn't know better
you know and now and now i know that it
wasn't her that was taking care of me
it was it was allah god almighty the
creator
it's it's really like it's it's really
it's really difficult to swallow that
pill you know
that he is over everything else and
nothing happens because
nothing happens until he says it you
know and i and i knew like they were
everybody would tell me like even when i
was in prison
i had no family i had nobody to that
that would take care of me and
every time there was someone there that
that was taking care of me
i found out that they were like they
were doing witchcraft on me right
with with this with this particular
thing
and um that they were working me with um
with uh with they they call it um
um what is it they go to a certain um
cemetery and and they work they work you
so you can so you can
die so so they make they they do a lot
of witchcraft craft
new mexico they deal with a lot of gin
over there in in mexico
but i i wasn't a believer you know i had
not like even even though like i had it
i had her there
i was like man but now now that you know
uh from studying islam you know that
this is what they were dealing with
making connections with jinns
yes they were making this world of the
evil spirits
but you know what like and now i know
like be like
the person that was that was doing this
to me he thought that that
that those people were gonna that those
that they were gonna affect me
but god used these people to take care
of me
all all my time in prison
the same people that would come up would
be believers would be believers in in
in this in in this in this uh thing
and then instead of costing me harm they
would benefit me
and benefit me in the form that like
they're they were
like they in prison you find out who are
your real friends
because you can't give them anything and
and instead of them
like looking down on me they would help
me out and they would tell me like
you're you're going to be someone man
you're different
they would always tell me that like
you're different you have different you
you have a different mentality you're
you're a very smart person and now
without and like i would always say
i'm not here to stay you know even
though i knew i had murder i had murder
and
i was facing up to 20 to 35 years in
prison i i was going to spend the rest
of my life there i was not scared you
know
i would tell them like i'm not here to
stay man i'm here to grow
i'm here to learn and i'm going to come
out even stronger
not knowing that not knowing that i was
going to find guidance to
to what i now know no
but tell us go ahead
when i came out and and i was and i was
doing that uh a certain friend that was
really involved in in witchcraft
and and and and all this he told me he's
like hey
there's this there's this uh witch
that wants to do a cleaning on you
because he's saying that you have that
they're that they're working you
and i was like nah i'm good man he's
like he says that you're gonna end up
you're gonna end up very in a very bad
position
any and he's like and they're working
you with you with that same saint that
you have on your on
on because i had a talisman right he's
like they're working with you with their
they're doing something to you and not
knowing
not knowing what what like what they
were doing like i didn't really pay
attention to it
but allah allah was protecting me from
everything that they were doing because
nothing that they would do
would actually get to me when and when i
left everything
when i started when i when i when i left
everything behind i even like the day
the day that i decided to leave
i i ripped it off my my neck and i threw
it
i threw it and and i and i said to
myself like
what am i doing like i didn't even
believe in this and i'm falling into
this
because i would see things going on in
my life when i decided to to
accept islam and i was doing my prayers
it was difficult because i don't have
anywhere to go you know to this day i
don't have anywhere to
to go to like try to get knowledge the
only knowledge that i have
is by reading the quran and and what
allah
gives me to understand you know and and
and seeing your videos man i'm a big fan
of yours
i always see your videos and and they
they really motivate me you know i had
the the
i i woke up for five year prayer right
i went i went back to bed and i started
looking at
how how shaytan became and his purpose
brother like not a minute passed
when i felt like something get on top of
me right
i couldn't move like i tried to i tried
to talk
and i i felt like like my lips were
sealed
i had never had any type of encounter
with jinns
like dad like i for me that was like
just like go like
like stories to scare kids right
i felt this gin grab my ham brother
like he grabbed he his his fingers were
so long
that he went like this and he wrapped he
wrapped his hand
like on mine and and
i and i was fighting like i was laying
down without like not
being able to move and and i even tried
to move my hand
and i like he grabbed like he grabbed
the hold of my
twice i felt his fingers go like this he
picked me up
out of my bed and turned my head like
head bottom
and he dragged me in the middle of the
room i was scared that he was gonna let
me go and i was gonna
like i was gonna break my neck
the only thing i could say like the only
thing that i would that i i remember
was this is what i like i
i murmured it because i couldn't speak
but i said a lot but and like this
brother what did you say
you praised allah
just by like murmuring like i felt back
in my bed and
like the gin left right you felt the
grip let go
just by like just by trying to say
because i couldn't speak but just by
making the intention of glorifying god
like this gin dropped me boom
back on my bed i woke up and my heart
was like
i had never i had never encountered that
right
here in mexico they have like they have
a like a lot of people
say that they see demons and they see
james and
my neighbor that i didn't even like talk
to because i'm i'm a very
like i don't i don't have friends man i
keep everything to myself i don't go out
like he
knocked on my door and he's like hey can
i can i tell you something i was like
yeah
what's up man he's like um
there was i want to tell you something
but don't get scared i was like
yeah he did he doesn't know who i am
right he's like
there was there was three there was
three things there was three people
standing outside your house yesterday
i'm like what do you mean he's like
um they weren't people
he's like they were deemed like demons
right that's like they were they were
gin
that there were three dog talk three
dark tall jeans
outside my outside of my house
and and i told them like oh yeah i know
man
don't worry we left and i went back into
my
my room and i i just said alhamdulillah
god is good because the devil the devil
did not does not want to did not want to
let me go he was mad
you know that's how you you you
connected
because the previous lifestyle and all
of the horrible things you did from the
past
you were a good worker for him huh
exactly
and and and he wanted like he wanted
he knew he knew because like there's a
lot of things that have happened in my
life that i couldn't find explanation
to right a lot of things happened in my
life and and
i've had a lot of things happen that i
would like i would say to myself man
maybe you're crazy like why are you
having these why you having why are you
seeing these things
when i didn't believe in them and
when when i started like looking for for
a lot i started like concentrating on i
started saying i'm gonna change my life
i'm gonna be something better
if i was willing to die for for for for
those for those wrong reasons
now i'm going to do that for all the
right reasons
brother i had got this job right
the second day i became a muslim they
fired me
like everything started going against me
like everything
and instead of instead of me getting
mad you know i i asked myself like
this is a test to know if you're if you
really want to change
or at the first at the at the first at
the first encounter of problems you're
going to run back to what you know
what what you used to know because that
was all i know i knew
to do what i used to do before i i don't
really want to say what i did because
it's
like glorifying that but i was a very
evil person you know
i would take care of business without
feeling any type of
without having a heart and
when when i started looking for god like
i started seeing how
i lost my job like everything was going
downhill
brother like people would call me up
like hey
we know you we know you left but we want
to we want you to take care of business
we're going to pay you this much money
like the money that they were offering
was
50 grand to take care of business
like offers were coming and coming for
me to
to to run back anybody would like
anybody would run back to that
right if i was if i didn't know what i
had encounter and i did if i didn't
know what what what a lot had guided me
to i would have done it because i had
that was my life that was stuff
that was what i used to do that was my
business
but i knew that inside of me i would say
are you gonna turn your back on your
creator now that he has guided me to
something that is true
i that is true i am
100 sure this is this is the true
religion
because like i talked to muslims and
they asked me how did you know about
how did you find out about islam
did someone preach to you did someone
share dawah with you
may allah continue to bless you my
brother we want to get you on these last
couple of minutes we have
we want to connect you how can people
now
for the spanish community you know to go
ahead you talked about you don't really
have a community there
and now you want to continue to learn
you want to grow
there's one new muslim academy academy
online that we recommend is for new
muslims right after they take shahadah
it's a course now
but then also bigger than that we want
to connect you we want to go ahead and
you know get you with the right people
there's our brothers from islamic
spanish.com have you heard of this
website islam islaminspanish.com
have you heard of that uh i think i have
yeah
uh but how could some of these uh
brothers
you know our hispanic latino brothers
you know connect with you you
you're currently uh are you in
california you're in mexico
i'm still in mexico i'm close to the
border
yeah um i don't really want to say where
i'm at because yeah
that's why you're that's why you were
wearing the glasses and the hat yeah a
lot of people want to see
want to me me in a very bad place
because yeah
i can imagine so uh if um
well we'll have them reach out to would
you
they they can reach out to you yeah and
and and um
you can you can your email i'll give you
your
yeah you have my information you know
okay and basically i was that's why i
try to reach
out to you man like because here like i
i sometimes like
i'm striving you know and and like
i'm not going to give up i'm not going
to give up now that i
i know what is what is real because i've
seen it
firsthand in my life you know and when i
started learning about the
the companions of of prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
like i would get goosebumps you know
because i was like man
i'm a warrior like i would have loved to
been i would love to be in there you
know
knowing that i was gonna die for the
right cause because like that's what
that's what i would always like that was
that was my main goal you know like
i'm i'm a warrior but now i know that
before before being a warrior i'm a
slave of allah you know
and i just i ask him for guidance every
day and and like
i have i've been going through some some
tough
the most the most important thing that
we can that we can have and that they
can never take away from us
we can lose everything we can lose
freedom we can lose
everything we can lose in this world
this this world
but the the guidance that he gives
is something that we really have to
appreciate
because not everybody is guided not
everybody has the knowledge that we have
and the knowledge that we have been
given
and it's really true i really hold that
dear that he guides who he will
you know and and that's why we see so
much people going astray and so much
people falling in
in in in that because they are they're
still not guided
but if you do if you do have guidance
and
you do believe in it don't ever let it
go because that is
that is the most that's the most
greatest thing we can have
the guidance of them all the of the
creators of the heavens and the earth
absolutely and they can never take that
away you know we can lose everything
i've lost everything and the only thing
i have is him
and that's the only thing i did you know
so i'm i'm happy
i'm happy i'm really love everything i
know everything's gonna
everything is is i'm getting to that
point and
i i really want to learn more because
like i talk to my friends you know i
have a lot of friends still
in that business and like they tell me
like hey we respect you man
we know we didn't like we're not you're
not the type of person that just like
turns you back like that he's been into
gunfights with you like we've been
in gunfights with you you're not you
ain't no coward
but you know and now i understand that i
have there's a great
there's a great plan
i want to be able to tell those people
that are in in the mafia they're in the
cartels because a lot of people like
they they think they don't have heart we
have a lot of heart
and i know that a lot of them are there
because they have they can have their
own reasons
but i want to share this message because
here in mexico there's basically no
muslims you know
there's very very few inshallah we can
get this uh you can get this message to
them
uh and share it with them so we'll try
to inshaallah connect you now we'll
many people will see this episode and
inshallah they reach out to us and we'll
try to make some connections
uh and then shall i go from there and i
appreciate man um
you giving me the opportunity to share
because i really didn't want to like
i was thinking of it like yesterday i
was just reaching out so like
so you can give me some advice i didn't
really want to come on the show and like
i'm i wasn't that i was like what am i
doing but
very very very inspirational story uh
live testimony to again someone who can
be in the darkest of
places in the world but so many gems
from your story
and one of the greatest is to call on
the crater alone without any talisman
without any [__]
without any saints but just the one god
the creator of the heavens and earth and
ask for guidance like you did
and when you were looking around left
and right where you're going to hang
yourself
you were asking right before that for
the guidance and you got guided that's
why you're here
with us on the dean's show turned to the
created heavens and earth in islam
and i've been eight months eight months
striving to become a better muslim
keep moving forward keep pressing
forward young brother check out this
this uh this website new
muslimacademy.com
it's a really good website and we'll try
to make those other connections
inshallah we'll send you the
okay nice it was nice meeting you and
like i hope you're blessed brother you
too brother opportunity
you're welcome salaam laker formally
brother thank you
wow can you imagine being in that
position now
that you go from california to mexico
and now you're
in the cartel and you're just doing you
can't imagine he didn't want to go into
the details
of any of the horrific things that he
did but then he just hightailed it out
of there
and then he's like hey he's about to i
mean the
just the darkness you know has overtaken
the heart and the soul and he's about to
commit suicide
he's looking around from the left to the
right where to hang himself
and he does look he don't know about
islam
the only thing he heard about islam he's
thinking these guys are terrorists
and now but he's doing something that's
innate in the human being he's calling
upon the creator of the heavens and
earth alone he's calling upon
the creator he's saying look guide me he
didn't call upon it he'd say jesus he
didn't
say god he didn't say allah he just said
guide me he but he was
calling sincerely to the one create to
the creator that's what
the main takeaway you can be in the
worst
place in your life you're not living
with purpose
but now you are sincerely wanting to
know your purpose in life you want to
know
where you're going when you die why
you're here ask the creator of the
heavens and earth ask from the depths
of your heart and soul sincerely guide
me guide me guide me
and you'll be surprised what happened
look what happened to our brother
our brother there this amazing story and
look at the perseverance
i'll make dua for him so he can remain
steadfast thank you for tuning in to the
show subscribe if you haven't already go
ahead and feel free to share all of our
episodes out there with the world
because through these stories we're
changing lives we're inspiring people
so they can go ahead and find their
purpose live their purpose
inshallah god one thank you peace be
with you assalamu alaikum